foreign
gunfire rings out Across The Plains of
Southern England
[Applause]
and there's another distinctive sound
commands barked out in a battlefield
first aid drill in Ukrainian
these men their identities protected
emerged recently from a past life as
lawyers engineers and accountants
to embrace a new calling as Defenders of
their Homeland against Russian invasion
most arrived here in England with no
military experience whatsoever
after five weeks of basic training
they'll soon be given orders to join the
deadliest front lines on the European
continent in nearly 80 years
as human beings of course we're afraid
of course we worry about our lives and
the lives of our families but we're
totally sure that we will win there is
no other option
commanders on the ground among the
multinational trainers here say their
mission is to do as much as they
possibly can in a short time to turn
these Ukrainian recruits from civilians
into soldiers they describe their
determination to learn as humbling
you fight off the missile or they're
taught weapons handling and Marksmanship
Urban tank and trench warfare
the training is spearheaded by British
troops part of a seven nation contingent
that aims to put 19
000 volunteer recruits through basic
infantry training in a matter of months
it's absolutely
um remarkable to see the passion the
energy and enthusian that these
volunteers have when they arrive here so
they might have come from the full
spectrum Society they could be bus
drivers journalists Architects but as
soon as they are here they're absolutely
focused to learn as much as possible and
prepare themselves for combat how long
it take to fight all these Rockets
my country is where my freedom lies and
that is something they want to take away
from me so it's not a question of Honor
it's a question of taking back what is
mind
it won't be long before he's given the
chance to try and do that Jonah Al
Jazeera in Southern England